ever since the apparent disappearance of
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile the
SCP Foundation had been growing Restless
all Personnel aware of the situation
were filled with conflicted feelings of
paranoia and relief perhaps at long last
one of the universe's most hateful and
dangerous anomalies was gone for good
and there had been no trace of the
monster since the chemical plant
explosion but given the cutter class
reptiles track record with all methods
of annihilation none of the researchers
were too optimistic in reality none of
them had any idea that the actual
whereabouts of scp-682 was five levels
deep into the sprawling seemingly
endless Labyrinth of liminal Dimensions
known simply as the back rooms it was a
far crueler and more alien reality than
any punishment that the SCP Foundation
could have dreamed up for the reptile
but nonetheless it was the reality that
scp-682 had to face after rampaging for
hours through what appeared to be an
infinite Hotel scp-68 82 was finally
able to check out of his unexpected stay
in the level 5 Resort as was becoming
routine at this point movement between
levels of the back rooms came down to
finding an ideal surface to noclip
further in the case of the entrance to
the back room's level six the hard to
destroy reptile managed to find such a
location in the vast Boiler Room of
level 5. with no reason to hesitate and
frankly being incredibly disgusted with
the appearance of human Hospitality in
the infinite Hotel
scp-682 vanished into the noclip surface
and re-emerged into the evidently pitch
black void of level 6. this new level
was dark absolutely so it was the kind
of advanced Darkness only observed in
the depths of our reality's largest cave
systems where no natural or artificial
light can reach 682 was not deterred by
this of course the highly adaptable
organism had already developed
sophisticated echolocation sonar in
order to navigate the yellow wallpapered
Maze of Level 1. A as well as infrared
night vision which it had heavily
utilized in level 2. the level 6
remained for all intents and purposes
concealed by Darkness
scp-682's evolved senses could easily
make sense of its layout aside from the
impenetrable shroud of Darkness that
pervaded the entire level the reptile
soon found level 6 to be largely
familiar territory like every previous
level of the back rooms that scp-682 had
traversed this level took the form of a
seemingly random arrangement of tight
hallways that stretched on for a
fathomless distance in every direction
more empty tunnels you've got to be
kidding me
scp-682 thought to itself this latest
infinite Labyrinth was the most infinite
and Labyrinthian of all the infinite
labyrinths that scp-682 had wandered
through since it no clipped into the
back rooms there was however something
unusually calming about this level as if
being here made the reptile that much
less driven to escape it still wanted
more more than anything to find more
living things to destroy but on level 6
it was decidedly willing to take its
time and see how far these tunnels would
go before it got its next fix of
violence what scp-682 didn't know is
that the darkness of level 6 was not
merely a property of a lack of lighting
and possessed the supernatural ability
to induce feelings of intense anxiety
and extensional Dread within any human
being's unfortunate enough to be trapped
within the emphasis being on the words
human being which scp-682 was anything
but while the scp's sudden shift in
Attitude might have been a side effect
of its adaptable nature it's very
possible that any sufficiently malicious
entity might feel right at home on level
six not that there appeared to be any
other entities present on this level
regardless the reptile was having a
grand old time moving from hallway to
hallway and for once it was starting to
see the appeal of delayed gratification
it wasn't overly concerned about not
encountering life on this floor because
and it's on the subtle mind
scp-682 was thinking how much of a
special treat it would be to be able to
destroy something entirely new whatever
it might be for all the predictability
of their maze-like structure the back
rooms were full of surprises case in
point
scp-682's recently adapted echolocation
picked up a single isolated humanoid
figure several hundred miles away the
reptile chuckled to itself what a sucker
this is too easy he began to leisurely
maneuver towards the lone humanoid who
curiously appeared to be standing in
that one place without any signs of
movement this pleased scp-682 and when
it eventually made its way to the room
where the humanoid was located it found
that its latest prey had been waiting
patiently for the inevitable Doom that
the creature would bring the strange
humanoid the only entity that scp-682
had encountered on level 6 appeared to
be an ordinary man standing next to an
enormous light switch on the wall hold
the switch please pull the switch the
man repeated he was a Sitting Duck
scp-682 was going to relish this one the
reptile moved forward with pointed
aggression and soon there was no man
standing there only the switch he once
begged passerbys to pull 682 proceeded
to exit the quiet room having no
interest in the light switch or what
might happen if it were pulled shortly
thereafter 682 began to hear scuttling
sounds within the darkness as if a giant
crustacean or insect were quickly moving
through the Halls the sensory data that
it was receiving from its echolocation
didn't detect any nearby forms of life
least of all with any Anatomy that would
correspond to those kinds of chitinous
sounds before long another sound became
faintly audible throughout level 6 that
of crashing ocean waves 682 had nothing
but time and no better place to go so
began to follow the sounds to towards
their Source gradually the tidal noises
increased in volume to the point that
even they began to overwhelm 682's very
own sound waves of echolocation although
temporarily struggling for direction
scp-682 felt a sudden decline in the
surface of the floor beneath its feet it
appeared to be a staircase and the ocean
waves could be heard coming from just
beyond as the reptile descended the
stairs the soothing feelings that had
accompanied it through its journey
across level 6 began to rapidly
dissipate when scp-682's claws touched
down on the final step all traces of
easy-going apathy had fully faded and
were replaced once again with the
boundless Spite and Malice that defined
its usual mindset it was pleasant while
it lasted
scp-682 now found itself in a damp room
full of assorted Furniture including a
bookcase with a few books a coffee table
and a single chair non-glitched to be
precise the puddle of water on the floor
beneath it was about three inches deep
the glow of a fluorescent ceiling lamp
was a stark departure from the utter
darkness of the previous hallways in
level six but of course it was different
this was level seven or rather the
entrance room to level seven
scp-682 had little reason to linger in
this place for long as the furniture was
neither alive nor large enough to
support its mass an open doorway
adjacent to the staircase appeared to
lead to a great body of salt water which
was doubtlessly the source of the ocean
noises as scp-682 continued its Advance
into this new layer it was suddenly met
with a change of gravity the moment that
it stepped in front of the doorway to
the ocean 682's relative relationship to
the entrance room's gravity shifted such
that the doorway became decidedly down
in a hilariously undignified fashion the
ketterclass anomaly tumbled through the
doorway to level 7 proper and plummeted
directly into the vast sea below this
was something new well level 7 was
without a doubt another impossibly huge
liminal nightmare Dimension contained
within the back rooms it wasn't another
Maze of hallways or at the very least it
didn't look like one though there was no
visible Sun anywhere on the horizon the
Blue Sky up above the ocean was well
illuminated as if to imply the presence
of daylight
scp-682 landed in the water beneath the
entrance room with a tremendous Splash
and instantly its body began to sink
deeper into what appeared to be an
immense Uncharted ocean without a sea
bottom within seconds 682's echolocation
adjusted to the underwater environment
becoming more like that of a dolphin
with this enhanced sonar as cp682
attempted to detect if there were any
living organisms within the immediate
area while the ocean was mostly devoid
of any new entities as was starting to
become customary in these new levels the
SCP did discover a series of barren
Rocky islands along the surface of the
water additionally there were bigger
shapes in the far distance which the
sonar could detect but due to their
colossal size the nature of these
unknown objects was well unknown some of
the strange shapes were drifting slowly
through the Deep indicating that while
the ocean of level 7 was far from a
thriving ecosystem it may yet contain
other beings that scp-682 could fight to
the death in order to cross the ocean
and find any of these potential
formidable entities
scp-682 would have to adapt its physical
form once again the first priority was
for it to grow a set of gills allowing
scp-682 to breathe in this underwater
environment then its four reptilian
limbs began to stretch and flatten
developing into full-sized aquatic
flippers the likes of which might be
found on a prehistoric whale or a
leopleurodon with these newly minted bad
boys scp-682 could gracefully glide
through the water like the angriest
submarine to ever Voyage to see if it
cared for petty thrills or the sensation
of freedom 682 may have perceived this
experience as fun however anything close
to a non-negative emotion that the SCP
was capable of had been left behind in
level 6. it was more Furious than ever
at its current predicament especially
because the encounter on the previous
level had been so brief and
anti-climactic as the leopleurodon mode
scp-682 zoomed deeper into the watery
depths of level seven the bright rays of
daylight from the level Sky became more
distant in this cooler and darker
Twilight Zone
scp-682 began to see bones floating in
the water the scattered remains of
humans and aquatic creatures could be
seen throughout this area of level seven
all entirely picked clean with perfectly
White Bones on display while typically a
creature being submerged this deep into
a terrestrial ocean from our reality
would result in a severe increase in
water pressure level 7 appeared to
remain at a constant and manageable
level of pressure insufficient to crush
even an ordinary humans count not that
this equivalent level of water pressure
would pose any threat or hindrance to
scp-682 and it continued its descent
away from the daylight Zone and further
into the Twilight Zone some of the
skeletons here were absolutely Titanic
in size clearly these were the Massive
Drifting shapes that scp-682's dolphin
sonar had sensed from the surface
whatever these things were they all met
their end a long time ago frustrated
that once again the back rooms had
denied it a meaningful challenge the
hard to destroy reptile almost didn't
see the Hostile entity darting towards
it with the intent to Seek and Destroy
682 wasn't the only creature in this
ocean with a numerical designation the
so-called entity 720 also commonly known
as Tiny smashed through the floating
skeletons and landed a glancing blow on
the SCP with his massive spear Who Dares
trespass in my domain tiny shouted the
entities bioluminescent body glowing
with arrogant Pride its words were
telepathic beamed directly into 682's
mind naturally 682 began to evolve
telepathy of its own in preparation to
respond while the Aquatic being was over
twice the size of scp-682 and armed with
a fearsome weapon of whittled bone no
doubt Carr from one of the many primeval
and unknowable skeletons of level 7. the
cutter class anomaly was not about to
back down from this obvious provocation
your domain 682 ground should I take you
that you are the ruler of this back
rooms is this where this commendable
Labyrinth ends entity 720 laughed with
an overconfident Bluster in spoke this
is level seven and I'm afraid you're a
great many levels away from the last one
but don't worry simple Beast I can
promise you that this is the last level
you'll ever see
scp-682 decided it didn't like this
thing it was acting far too cocky for
its own good you're a lonesome and
disgusting piece of work aren't you
again The Entity left in 682's face
likewise puny lizard he said shall I
teach you to fear me
scp-682 gnashed its teeth and exclaimed
that's my line neither of these monsters
was backing down and it was clear that
an epic battle between the two of them
was about to take place 682 rushed in
Jaws open wide to deliver a brutal bite
but entity 720 was deceptively fast for
its size and swung its spear into 682's
side catching its mid-aquatic charge and
sending it careening into a cluster of
floating ribs as if showing off tiny
twirled his weapon with a flourish
before unleashing a lightning fast
barrage of powerful spear thrusts to its
annoyance and surprise
scp-682 could feel its body sustaining
damage over the course of multiple
impacts he hated to admit it but this
was one entity from the back rooms that
wasn't all talk in response to Chinese
merciless attack plates of natural armor
began to cover scp-682 this improved its
defense but the SCP still needed to take
the fight to the entity or better yet
682 dodged one of the incoming spear
attacks and clamped its teeth around the
middle of the weapon it bit down like a
vice crushing a bit of bone but again to
its surprise failing to close its jaw
completely and thus being unable to
break the spear did you think that my
mighty spear would break so easily tiny
scoffed he Whirled the spear through the
water with enough Force to create a
tumultuous Whirlpool spinning 682 in
circles in an attempt to disorient it he
placed both his large hands on the lower
parts of the spear and with a precise
Swish and flick motion of a fisherman
casting a line launch the reptile flying
through the dapps how could this be
happening a cp682 wondered it roared in
Anger causing the water around it to
Ripple with the intensity of its sound
waves this caused an unforeseen reaction
in tiny who hesitated and double back in
response bonds to the noise
scp-682 grinned through its horrible
teeth so that was its weakness tiny
recovered from the shock of 682's Roar
moments later and it was seemed he was
trying to play his reaction off as
discussed pathetic now say good night he
said as he aimed to hit scp-682 with his
most powerful weapon strike yet tiny
struck his foe with all the force he
could muster running through it like he
was spearfishing but in response
scp-682 released a high-pitched Sonic
Screech That Shook the waters around
both adversaries even more than the last
the impact of the sound waves was so
powerful that all surrounding skeletons
began to shatter into small shards of
bone tiny was hit straight on with the
Sonic vibrations from scp-682's sensory
attack and was immediately rendered
unconscious sinking like a stone to the
area even deeper below the Twilight Zone
The Midnight Zone the fight between
scp-682 and entity 720 was effectively
over
scp-682 shook off the entity's final
blow and began to regenerate from all
his injuries that telepathic creature
had been by far the most challenging
thing that it had encountered during its
journey through the back rooms but the
increase in durability to its own armor
would prove useful in protecting the
reptile from any other entities with a
similar level of brood Force diving
after its Fallen Foe and hoping to
finish the job
scp-682 entered into the midnight zone
it descended past several more vaguely
humanoid skeletons and countless
fish-like skeletons which seemed to have
no real beginning or end apparently the
body of entity 720 had sunk quickly Out
Of Reach of the SCP or perhaps tiny had
fled the battle out of fear while
happiness and Triumph were not within
the emotional capacity of scp-682 it did
take a wicked sense of Glee in crushing
that entity's stubborn Pride it
continued to swim directly downward
emboldened by the Victory eventually
scp-682 came to the mouth of an enormous
Cavern towards the end of the midnight
zone the opening appeared to be within
the side of a tall underwater Mountain
while the thought of having to travel
through more narrow spaces reminded it
unfavorably of its containment facility
scp-682 was beginning to accept that the
back room's rarely manifested as one
open space if claustrophobic caves and
corridors were the one consistency
scp-682 had long been accustomed to
those kinds of spaces sure enough
entering the midnight Mountain soon
revealed the entrance to the lair of the
Sorceress oh my apologies that's a
completely different story about a
feisty reptile traveling through
Forgotten Realms and defeating
everything in its path this isn't Spyro
explained its SCP explained getting back
on track 682 arrived in a Subterranean
system of Rocky tunnels which while no
longer entirely were totally submerged
was damped with water almond water
because what else this was the back
rooms level 8. despite the fact that the
entrance to level 8 was beneath the
midnight zone of level 7 and there
appeared to be no natural source of
light the visibility Within These
Caverns was surprisingly high it was to
the point that even an average human
could with little effort perceive their
surroundings here is this some kind of
sick joke
scp-682 thought to itself if whoever
trapped me in these back rooms things
they can contain me in a place humans
could survive I must show them just how
wrong they are when I find them it's on
sight since 682 had already developed
echolocation and night vision level 8
wasn't exactly a new frontier yet it
began to Dawn on the hard to destroy
reptile that this might be all the back
rooms was a never-ending collection of
cavernous New Dimensions to wander
aimlessly until it stumbled across the
entrance of the next level by chance it
could go on forever with seemingly no
Rhyme or Reason though the oceans of
level 7 had presented 682 with the
concept that the back rooms might have
an outside that could be used as a means
to escape back to its native reality the
truth appeared to be that there was no
distinction between an exterior and an
interior Within These Dimensions from
the second it had no clipped into this
place 682 might have effectively been
condemned to meander through infinite
levels of the back rooms Until the End
of Time discourage wasn't the right word
for how 682 was feeling it was far more
accurate to say that the reptile was
absolutely fuming with barely restrained
rage for the unfathomable Cosmic forces
that had brought it here they would all
pay dearly for the disgusting indignity
it had suffered as scp-682 progressed
deeper into the winding tunnels and
echoing caverns of the back rooms level
8. it found itself surrounded Once More
by a hostile swarm of death moths the
larger females began to spit acid
melting away portions of the armor its
body had worked so hard to adapt it
always had to be acid 682 let out a low
rumbling noise that sounded somewhat
like a sigh of exasperation after its
intense and thrilling battle with tiny
was it really going to have to return to
destroying these worthless bugs that
even those Weak Knee jelly bags on the
mobile task forces could handily
dispatch you idiot creatures do you have
any idea what you're dealing with here
scp-682 grumbled the death moths didn't
respond they merely continued to Flap
around in the air around the scp's head
and bombard the reptile with more acid
682 was positively seething know your
place it mercilessly devoured every last
death moth before making its way deeper
into level 8. perhaps with the Myriad of
monsters said to lurk in this level
scp-682 would find itself faced with
another worthy Challenger after all now
go check out part one and two of the
scp-682 versus the backroom series to
relive all the insane extra dimensional
reptile Carnage that brought us back to
now